[Music]
orbiting is an installation piece that
is circled around machine and the
machine creates floating objects were
very particular material and these
objects find a particular choreography
in the space and the idea is also to
create a very unreal atmosphere of that
no one has ever done it to make or to
make the machine that produce 40 ohms it
so that's us from the scientific or
engineering point of view it's really
interesting so right now we're still
looking for a new material that is very
low density we were trying everything we
could do in a very fun way so that's why
I think we found the material from very
daily object like a class or Babu
it may take like three years more but if
as long as we have this like final goal
to be realized I think this process
every step is really meaningful here oh
she is she is and scientists that has a
very artistic approach towards processes
of production processes of research he
has a very good idea of the aesthetical
outcome of it and also in this work does
the tangible media loop I think there is
a clear awareness that aesthetics adds
some kind of meaning to an object or to
a machine that goes beyond the pure
functionality so artistically Tom
project not to the meaning he want to
make many objects which represent
cultural symbol floating in the air
circulating and then disappear process
is very ephemeral and usually we have a
final artifacts like objects look in a
science stick work published paper is a
final product but all the process travel
discussion prototyping fading laughing
or crying never be captured but that has
a real essence of the collaboration of
joy was a barrier
if we work with many people who have
different perspective you can really
expand
yes cough and the boundaries as an
engineer and a scientist that really
piqued my interest because I feel like
in art you can ask these sorts of
questions that aren't practical and that
maybe have no immediate function or
utility but ultimately push the bounds
of what we can think of and what we can
do if you want to make stuff float you
need a very very thin pliable elastic
material that you can kind of blow up
and maximize the surface area it's a
volume ratio Tom for this orbiting
project wanted to do the opposite he
wanted a material that was rigid that
could be molded into a shape and then
right as it's molded and inflated with
helium could just float away off of off
of a fabrication machine and here it was
really just a simple question can you
make stuff float that takes on new
geometries and has new properties and
what is the fabrication technology you
need to do that all the stuff floating
in the air in something very strongly
implemented a brain
so even project does not beached at the
point hope we can keep dreaming the
world with which we can really controls
gravity they make things float in the
air at all wheel
you